all right so uh what I was talking in
the interview about how you get in
someone's space so it's helpful to think
of their space as kind of like this egg
shape right so funny just like my
spiders is going crazy right now yeah
espe when you the nature what that I
could do that to you and you show me
where everything is uh Grant it because
there's nothing that we're doing to fool
anyone so we'll see this I put this is a
jacket I brought for you just because
people don't wear Jack like that anymore
I've learned they do in New York they do
they do do yes yeah but for a lot of
hard to find you can have it 40 40
regular the eyes yeah turns out my jeans
there it do but there are some things
that we put on you wallet we put a pen
and the goal of this is I'll talk about
the difference of how I steal things and
how a thief would steal them on the
street okay so we'll show you the
difference of a couple of those and how
to get in space so one of the benefits
in the way that I steal stuff um as I
approach your space so you can feel like
the spidey sense going off now and I'm
at it I'm at your space now I'm inside
of it Square on yes and now I'm out
outside of it but that shift is a
different thing that a lot of people
aren't quite aware of it is but even you
see like how I step back with one hip I
shift the weight back yeah all those
things are intentional to control the
dynamic versus squaring up this way is a
different thing yeah and the same thing
You' got in martial arts the ability to
have that softness is a useful thing
sometimes not Telegraph but if I want to
get inside the
space if I walk up and I walk into your
space this way now if I come in and I
break on eye contact I share something
with you this way it feels fairly
natural like we're sharing right right
we have Confluence but if I keep eye
contact as we go into that that feels
bit different and and it can move away
or even if you don't even if you don't
move if I if I come here I keep ey
contact with you it's really hard not to
look at me yeah yeah but try not to so
try just so so if I show you a document
or something like this and I'm keeping
my head it's still the Spidey sent right
don't like it so that's a human behavior
piece that's normal and what it does is
it chops up your attention because
you're thinking about other things so at
any time where I don't want be focused
here I can just look up just too close
yeah and that creates that thing and
I'll use that now what if I gave you
something and if I put something in your
hand now that whatever it is that I give
you uh my driver's license say just keep
it that way uh but when you go look at
that that now creates a frame that works
against you because you can't see
through your arm so now anything I
wanted to extract off this side you
wouldn't see same thing if somebody's
carrying their cell phone they're
looking at it they can't see this side
it's their own manufactured blind spots
so being able to extract so a bigpocket
would keep a 45 degree angle off the
backside or straight behind you and
their teammates would be there they
might lock an elbow so that you could
get the elbow back as during an
extraction but that ability to take of a
space when I was telling you about the
Secret Service when they were
approaching uh they stepped back like
you did initially they Ste back there
this way they pivoted back on one foot
yeah right but why do it yes exactly
that yeah uh so in that case said you've
been trained I'm not going to be able to
do this but you you're rather easy so
now when I come to this guy this guy
just gave me access so as I do
extractions I leave the items underneath
my arm and I steal some things out and
do it that way so the r that you still
like I talked about we mentioned this
term kissing the dog all of this when I
perform is kissing the dog that's
drastically different than the street
right so one of the problems on the stre
handicapping yeah it is because you
remember me because you now know what I
look like so how do I steal from you
without you seeing me extract from
inside so right now like you have a
wallet there so one way to beat that and
they call this playing up town in the
spot so if I'm playing up toown or
playing the pit uh which is a hard
extraction one way that I might do that
if I have a backpack and if we're in the
subway so if I'm here and I'm in front
of you if I I'm going to move you just a
little bit this way so the camera can
kind of see a little bit better but
let's use this pill just as an
improvised kind of backpack prop okay so
if I'm handing a backpack back to a
friend this way now if the subway is
compact is tight as I give the this way
this now functions lot Lin spot yeah so
I can Comm in do an extraction so if I
lock in this case we have a pen there if
I lock on the wallet now when I go to
take that wallet out I pass that to them
and now as this come back as my arm
comes down the extraction can be
misattributed to my elbow coming down
right in terms of the contact and they
take that backpack but on the other side
they take this wallet off to the side so
that's a way that can play just by
passing a thing over here broughts you
up gets me here and then I pass it back
and I can walk away a slight kissing the
dog yeah it's not the full thing first
is like with me when I'm
stealing I might look to check what
somebody has and as I extract maybe for
example uh so actually one tip real
quick for a big Pockets perspective a
bfold wallet like this has names so this
part right here is called the feet which
is the feet these two parts right here
okay this is the head okay so this is it
standing on its feet in a pocket this is
it standing on its head and this is
laying bit okay so if I want to take it
out of your pocket it's better if it's
not standing on its head because it can
catch and in this case that's why I just
detected with the pen is that the pen
was inside of it was standing on its
head okay so they sometimes would say I
need to take it out of bed first so one
move one old play would just be taken
out of bed moving it to that position
the orientation yeah and then stopping
waiting it's kind of like sneaking up on
rabbits when the antenna goes up you
stop and you wait you do small beats so
if I wanted to get into uh this pocket
here for example what I might do is I
hit the wall so two things I can go in
and extract it while I'm talking about
the jacket but then I can just leave it
in place so now it's clear of the pocket
but I'm holding it with my pinky so it's
a little DeLay So by setting the time
delay I can do something else but now as
my jacket that hang goes underneath it's
easier to do extraction l or I can take
it up and make it a little bit more
showy if I'm showing off for the people
around yeah so that's the style it's a
little bit more Harlem Globe Trotter
yeah and that way doing these type of
things but in that I was learning flare
bartending to learn how to throw a
wallet so all those skills kind of
marrying together with a lot of
it so I guess if I want to cause
problems got feed up you could yes
rubber bands do not help for some reason
in America there's this rumor that if
you put a rubber band around a wallet
makes it hard to come out of a pocket it
doesn't they also believe if you put in
the front pocket it helps but it doesn't
jeans help a little bit because you have
to be really intimate with someone to
kind of get into the pocket in a
performing context I can justify where
I'm not talking to you you I can come in
you go in your pocket and sometimes get
it out that way but jeans are harder
than slacks slacks front pocket are
extremely easy they get hit a lot and
for p pockets on the street if there's a
wallet in the back pocket they'll cut
like an l-shape and they just push down
and the contents come out us to cut
exact change my culture there is a
culture in Peru that carry a blade in
their mouth and they're amazing at
spitting it to their hand so they spit
it to their hand slice and put it back
so they have it concealed in the mouth
my brothers used to do the L cut that's
why I know that one so they would cut
with an L they push that way they cut
the bottom of a purse and push that that
way but there's a lot of those things
like one of things that people say well
I'll keep my hands in my pocket but
they'll do different things maybe they
tilt your hat or maybe they do a
cigarette burn in the back of the neck
you go like that and those little
movements are enough for the rest of the
team while you tribute that one guy
right to do an extraction sometimes One
play is that somebody just goes to take
their jacket off and maybe they put
their computer bag between their legs
and while they're taking their jacket
off it occupies them so I've seen that
they extract the laptop braid out of a
computer bag so you still think you have
it while you're taking the jacket off so
there's very bold mov because that
jacket functions as a shield but it is
very
improvisational but also the combination
of you have to know how to build a plane
if you're going to try to build the
plane on the way down yeah yeah totally
all right so what
else from a concept perspective or
technique perspective would form some of
the fundamentals uh
either what you do or what thieves might
do yeah well I'll show you a couple
things that are specific to my SL of
hand style um one thing is when I'm
approaching someone I'm using their
hands if if I can see your hand I'll
give you something like the coin that we
were talking about a while ago if I'm
giving you that coin to watch right now
it feels like you could turn your hand
over but I'm holding on to your thumb so
as you try it doesn't feel like it's
being controlled right and as it come
same thing if I use this hand so I can
control that I can control the speed at
which it turns over same thing when I
reach for this hand I now stop this
elbow from going back so there's all
these little mechanics of locking the
body up so it thinks it still has
choices but it doesn't so you're
bifurcating those choices a little bit
amazing yeah and a lot of those things
if you do this let me see your hand this
way so you can kind of see you can feel
the Palm my hand but if you put your
hand flat against the back of my hand
over there both hands together if I were
to get the coin out of my sleeve there
it is it goes to your hand do you fill
it right
there uh just thing right but that comes
from kind of and that's the flying up
thing they were talking about for long
yeah but those mechanics of managing
what they're paying attention to but
that combined both the controlling of
the movement with also controlling what
you feel and don't feel yeah so even
though you think you feel everything or
you're in control of it you can still
manipulate that wow all right how does
it change when you have say multiple
people and we could use the the pillow
as a prop if it's helpful but in terms
of navigating space you gave the example
of the two Secret Service agents and how
you sidled up turning this way to the
second agent leaving this guy exposed
right under the arm yep any other ways
to think about interacting with multiple
people because for you not only are you
kissing the dog you might be kiss
kissing multiple dogs in the sense that
you have witnesses right absolutely or
at attention yeah they at attention
they're on top of it they're trying to
be vigilant trying to be uh so in that
context like if I am multiple people if
I want to hit this guy but I know want
to do the next guy so maybe one move
might be if I give him something to pay
attention to let's just use like a
wallet like we had
before so if I'm going to go after that
wallet one thing I can do as I come to
pull that here if I take out that he's G
be very curious what that is meanwhile
the wallet goes because this is that
half circle line we were talking about
before right if you notice that it draws
his attention because it's a strange
thing he's trying to do the accounting
what is that does that belong to me it's
also an unnatural movement in a sense
right it is it's it's an
inefficient and it's very s for that
reason and if it's if I now pull a
straight line though you have both see
so you feel the difference I can't do
anything with this hand but if I come up
this way and draw your attention as you
lock onto that and I can feel you
locking on I can do the extraction bring
it over that way but now in that same
way when I say is this yours to this guy
where I can say is this yours over there
and now as I do that it seems to be gone
it's just underneath my arm but I'll use
those kinds of movements as I extract
their things and I'll sometimes place it
back on the guys so maybe as I ask you
to hold on to a thing I leave somebody's
wallet underneath your arm yes and they
won't know for that the wallet's under
their arm as long as they're holding on
to that and if they start to move it I
just move their elbow I just come back
so I'll use their body to hold on to
stuff from for a little while too and
how do you think about extractions with
say lucier material so front pockets on
slacks something like the jacket versus
the ring or a watch or something like
that it
seems From
manav's perspective to be more difficult
it does uh it just seems like I I
imagine most people who are listening
who have never had something
demonstrated on them like this would say
I would know if somebody pulled a ring
off my hand I would know if someone took
a watch off well like a ring if you have
your hands up in the air there's decid
that models try to keep their hands up
in the air before they put their hands
under a camera because the veins will be
less and the blood will flow down
because if they have their hands down
they'll be a different color and you can
kind of test that if you want to feel
the difference between the two but
there's also this idea that the fingers
become tender some people believe that
that might be approach what I've seen is
like for pal reading is if there's a
ring here is trying to hold the hand to
read a palm but it puts him in position
for the pinky to grab the ring as well
and now maybe I can't read your Lifeline
as well so I use a little bit of oil on
that so now that oil me see a little bit
better but also gives me a little bit of
lubrication for that so now when I talk
to you about other things I can extract
the ring so it's a lot of times about
the justification if you were to steal
something else like a watch again a
different justification so for me if I'm
trying to steal your watch from this
position I have to have a reason to
touch your
wrist or I have to cover it with
something else to be able to do
extraction on the street an approach
might be one they will sometimes do that
where they're trying to move someone in
this position to get a justification for
the watch but another one let's say it's
expandable watch that comes over the end
of the wrist they would have expand it
then you reach inside of a bag and this
is in Alejandra I saw this outside of
konata SP so when you come out of there
there was these ladies and they had a
bag of uh kind of like tea leaves and
you reach inside and as you pull those
out you're trying to extract a read do a
reading about this Leaf but what they do
is they expand the watch and when your
hand goes inside they leave the watch
inside the bag and you take your hand
out of the that could be like a Rolex so
they get very good at the combination of
the mechanics of undoing the Buckle and
things like that for me that's a lot of
the things that I would do are different
ways to do the Buckle and I'll show one
that's not the technique I regularly use
but if you do this same kind of a
different way if you can imagine shaking
hands all these small motions coming
through so now somebody still that the
watch is there but now as I reach by a
jacket it now seems to disappear off
there so that's more of a demonstrative
way than the way you reg do it but you
can see the mechanics that I can
unbuckle the watch give the appearance
it's still there and then steal it off
FFF it off yeah how would that differ
from I mean you don't need to show it if
you don't want to but yeah there's a
handful that I don't have on camera just
yeah it's an interesting thing so when
the New Yorker wrote about me versus
when they showed it in the video I
realized I hadn't stolen in my full
speed on camera before and it did affect
so a lot of people would watch me and
then come see me live and they would
know it's possible so now as I I've
developed new steals I tend not to put
those on camera the demo steals to show
if someone doing show motion it would
look like this yeah that makes sense all
right well thank you very much anything
else that uh we should cover do you feel
like that's a good I think ABC good I I
think like we talked about some places
to keep your stuff this pocket inside is
a good place to keep some belongings it
makes it hard for people to steal for
bit pocketing but for robbing it's a
different thing give up something else
give having a second wallet it's a very
useful thing the other thing is um there
are these Loops type wallets that can
attach to your belt and they flip on the
inside of the P it's different kind of
money belt it's a it's a pouch that
loops on and I'm sure you can put this
up as learned F shuts yeah and it you
flip it out and you put your contents in
there just don't use that for your
purchases when you go to the bathroom
take out whatever you need out of that
and use it but keep another wallet
that's there for somebody to steal and
it yeah it has some things are
meaningless it's just enough for to
satiate their curiosity and then the
other tip was the coffee cup that if you
have rings or unimportant important make
the unimportant important just by having
an or the important unimportant in this
case both sides inside the cop upup is a
nice improvised safe that you can use
perfect thank you thank you very much
really appreciate
it
that